Henry, je sais que déménager dans une nouvelle maison peut
être un peu effrayant, mais vous vous y habituerez.
Qu'est-ce que
notre fils a apporté à cette poupée d'une manière
que nous trouvons peut-être un peu étrange, mais cela
semble être thérapeutique,
appuyez et vérifiez votre  téléphone à
tes [ __ ] je me manque ok choquant tu
veux jouer Allons jouer Hé attends attends
attends sur Verizon
tu n'es pas le producteur de Deep line
où est ma sœur Chucky Chucky
Caroline tu n'es pas obligé de faire ça je suis
son nouveau  ami de la fin, lâchez votre couteau si
vous voyez les nouvelles, c'est que Chucky à la
Maison Blanche, nous sommes responsables de Chucky,
nous allons à Washington, il sait où
est ma sœur,
ah
encore,
il est mignon à la Maison Blanche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je pense que vous avez trouvé le Bureau Ovale très
intéressant
[Musique] de
quoi parlez-vous, les gars, de tuer des
gens, qu'est-ce que c'est que
d'étranger
[Musique]